à Fontenay-le-Fleury les automobilistes
doivent désormais lever le pied sous le
panneau d'entrée de ville une
signalisation zone 30 km/h est installée
depuis mai 2023 cette limitation est
désormais appliquée à l'ensemble des
Russes sauf exception l'an passé un
groupe de travail composé de fontnésiens
c'était réuni pour évoquer la vitesse
dans la commune conclusion pour
augmenter la sécurité des différents
usagers s'affranchir des 50 km/h était
préconisés on a une ville qui a été
tracée dans les années 70 qui est 100%
orienté voiture et la voiture reste mode
dominante ce qu'on cherche à faire là
c'est un meilleur partage de l'espace
public en protégeant les nouveaux
utilisateurs même s'ils sont les moins
nombreux ce sont les plus fragiles c'est
à dire les piétons et les trottinettes
un nombre d'accidents réduit grâce aux
nouvelles limitations le maire de
Fontenay-le-Fleury espère développer
l'usage du vélo encore trop minoritaire
sur sa commune à condition que cette
nouvelle règle soit appliquée par les
automobilistes moi aussi je suis
chauffeur conducteur et on fait pas
toujours attention à ce qu'on
la loi qui est écrit et on oublie c'est
pas respecté parce qu'il y a pas
suffisamment de personnes pour faire
respecter la loi pour l'association
Prévention Routière signalisation et
aménagement doivent être mis en place
par ces communes panneaux ralentisseurs
et rond-points peuvent t'aider à faire
freiner les véhicules mais chacun doit
aussi s'impliquer on parle de prévention
participative on doit pas attendre tout
de l'autorité publique il faut aussi
soi-même participer par son propre
comportement en montrant l'exemple voici
Miley hameau ou Villepreux les communes
zone 30 se multiplient dans le
département depuis plusieurs années de
son côté le maire de Triel-sur-Seine a
fait machine arrière en octobre 2022 les
Russes ont repassés à 50 km/h sauf au
niveau des écoles de la gare ou du
centre-ville selon lui les bienfaits
écologiques et la baisse des accidents à
30 km/h ne sont pas justifiés il y avait
beaucoup d'automobilistes qui ne
respectaient pas les distances de
sécurité avec le 30 km/h parce qu'il ne
comprenait pas la mesure qui n'était pas
crédible et donc n'arrivait pas à
l'appliquer donc on avait des comp
ortements dangereux donc il y a beaucoup
de triés lois qui se sentaient pas à
l'aise là on est sur un axe assez dégagé
et donc on peut rouler facilement à 50
km/h parce qu'elle est trottoirs sont
larges la route est assez grande il y a
aucun risque pour finalement pour les
automobilistes ni cyclistes ni les
piétons en 2021 l'Organisation des
Nations Unies lancé sa compagne loft 30
pour promouvoir la généralisation des
villes à 30 km/h dans le monde a besoin
encore important de pédagogie pour faire
accepter cette vitesse au plus grand
nombre